جهود الانقاذ في مدينه انطاكيا بولايه
هاتاي ما زالت مستمره في محاوله للوصول
الى اشخاص ما زالوا عالقين تحت الانقاض في
هذا الموقع نجح فريق انقاذ من قرغيزستان
بانتشال عائله سوريه مكونه من اب وام وطفل
بعمر 12 عاما كانوا احياء عند انتشار
الطفل كان مصابا واثناء محاولات فرق
الانقاذ والطواقم الطبيه انقاذه توفي
الطفل وبقي الاب والام بحاله جيده وتم
نقلهما الى مشفى في مدينه اضنه ايضا تم
انتشار جثتين لطفلين تعتقد السلطات انهما
اطفال العائله السوريه التي تم انقاذها
وتم نقل الاب والام الى اضنه في العموم
اعمال البحث والانقاذ ما زالت مستمره في
300 موقع وتحديدا في اربع ولايات في هاتاي
كهرمان مرعش وبدرجه اقل في اديمان في ديار
بكر في موقع وحيد زيدان زنجلو من مدينه
انطاكيا هاتاي